David Attenborough:
Join us for Prehistoric Planet
2.
(Roar)
(Roar!)
♪♪
David Attenborough:
Sixty-six million years ago,
planet Earth was ruled by dinosaurs.
David Attenborough:
Both majestic and extraordinary.
The mysteries of their lives
have been largely undiscovered.
David Attenborough:
Until now.
♪♪
(Roars)
David Attenborough:
Join us for a journey like no
other.
David Attenborough:
Where there is always more to
experience.
David Attenborough:
And more to discover.
♪♪
David Attenborough:
Explore five new worlds,
♪♪
David Attenborough:
filled with danger-
♪♪
David Attenborough:
-and adventure.
♪♪
(Roar)
(Roar!)
♪♪
David Attenborough:
This is Prehistoric Planet 2.
♪♪
David Attenborough:
Only on Apple TV Plus.